russia's war on ukraine was initially
seen as a regional conflict but it is
having increasingly global repercussions
upending geopolitics and sparking
tensions far beyond europe
both sides are forging new alliances
with countries they only recently kept
at arm's length russia turning to an
iran still aspiring to be a nuclear
power
joe biden swallowing his pride in a
controversial visit to saudi arabia
which just three years ago he called a
pariah so on to the point we're asking
new alliances in troubled times is it
anything goes for biden and putin
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to greet our guest susannah
koba is foreign correspondent for the
german news magazine der spiegel
and it's a pleasure to welcome tyson
barker he's an expert on foreign and
transatlantic relations and geopolitics
at the german council on foreign
relations dga
and ulrika herman covers business and
economics for the berlin-based daily the
tats
tyson barker many commentators referred
to biden's fist bump with saudi arabia's
crown prince as nothing less than a cow
tau
will it succeed in actually
reviving the u.s saudi alliance and
delivering the benefits biden's looking
for well the optics were terrible and
the optics were you know reverberated
through congress through washington
through the united states but the
substance of the meeting with the gcc
plus three were
quite successful and i think that they
show the embryonic beginnings of a new
coming together between saudi arabia and
the united states in some areas where
it's quite important for for the region
how do you measure success in that case
well there are some there are some you
know baby step deliverables for example
the decision to have israeli overflight
rights to saudi arabia the flight from
uh from israel to jeddah is a first time
uh flight and that is opening up a new
kind of soft accession of saudi arabia
to the abrahamic courts this
normalization accord that
the trump administration agreed to with
several uh arab states to normalize
relations with israel that's one another
is uh china is trying to play an
increasing role in the middle east
through the sale of technology
particularly walkways 5g technology and
the decision by
saudi arabia to exceed to the open ran
alliance and finally the issue of
this yemen
weapons drawdown the standstill in yemen
starts to open up the possibility for
closer security uh relationship between
the united states and saudi arabia
because that is a big sticking point for
congress
there's one element
tyson didn't stress there susanna but
many people say it's the element that
this visit was all about namely oil
in the beginning of this war there was a
lot of talk in the west about shared
values and the need to fight for western
values have geopolitics and resources
now eclipsed values
um i mean
eclipsed i would say that that would go
far beyond what's what's happening and
before that i mean there there have been
70-something years of very close
relations between saudi arabia and uh
and and and the us and the which is very
much about oil which was extremely much
about more oil but also about regional
influence it was also about
controlling iran it was also about
business i mean saudi arabia is such a
heavyweight in that region that you
cannot ignore it and i think there was a
hope
um i mean obviously in the in the
administration maybe also
or obviously in the in the obama
administration that you could refrain
from that very difficult relationship
because certainly saudi arabia is not
only exporting oil it's also exporting a
very extreme
version of islam which has
had a lot of very bad repercussions
and
they were of the opinion that they could
be more independent of that and now it
turns out and it actually now turns out
in particular with the euro ukraine war
that
you need you need
a cooperation a good cooperation with
saudi arabia for many reasons starting
with
if the if the nuclear
agreement with iran is not is not
be able cannot be
revived
which has a lot of
a lot of consequences and it looks like
right like that then about oil prices
yes
there is not so much there is not so
much um that
saudi arabia can do now to to deliver
more oil which has a lot of uh reasons
but at the end of the day certainly i
mean opec is sitting on
presiding over over the whole system of
of of of oil deliveries so it's a very
important uh meeting i think and i want
to come back uh to that point but but
rika uh let's just take a look at the
memorandum that was signed by iran and
russia because on his own trip to the
middle east uh putin was also talking
about oil
and iran is now offering a welcome
market will in fact this stronger
relationship between russia iran and
turkey that was on show there at the
summit in tehran will that deliver the
benefits that this very isolated russian
president needs well you know it was
very interesting to see that in fact the
roles are now reversed because now iran
is the strong partner it's no longer
russia and that is of course
humiliating for russia and the same
thing will happen with china
as china again is much stronger than
russia so what you could see there
is that russia is losing its status as a
superpower because it exhausts itself in
the ukraine it is not going to win this
war this will be a poor state or
afterwards and that was on show in at
this meeting now looking at turkey i
think that for erdogan
the u.s in fact is more important than
russia
the whole safety of turkey bases
in the end on the uh support of the
united states but of course you know
what erdogan tries to do is to somehow
be an independent power between russia
and
the united states to get some
leverage points there and of course he
wanted to have an agreement on north
syria because he wants to invade there
but that is something that iran and
russia won't agree to and i want to pick
up on exactly that point uh in just a
moment but first let's take a closer
look at biden and putin's middle eastern
speed dating in search of new and
distinctly unholy alliances
those two fists would herald a new era
between the u.s and saudi arabia
relations between the two countries have
long been at an all-time low ever since
saudi arabia had saudi journalist and
dissident jamal khashoggi murdered
now the turnaround
let me state clearly
that the united states is going to
remain an active engaged partner in the
middle east
but rather than concrete results the u.s
president was only given a vague promise
by saudi arabia to increase oil
production in the future
significantly more harmonious at least
outwardly was the tripartite meeting of
russia iran and turkey in tehran
its main focus was syria where all three
countries are engaged in war
also discussed on the sidelines a
possible iranian drone delivery to
russia and how to handle sanctions
for president putin the meeting was
above all a message to u.s president
biden and the west russia is also
engaged in this region
putin or biden
who has the upper hand in the middle
east
tyson what would you say to that
question in the face of the u.s chaotic
departure from afghanistan in the face
of what is often perceived as u.s
indifference in the face of the fighting
in syria does anybody really believe
biden's promises to
remain as he says an engaged partner
well i think that you know these
relationships are very deep the
relationship the united states has with
israel with egypt with saudi arabia with
the gulf states has clearly predated
biden and is something that has many
many tenants within the u.s political
system including in congress there are
different uh sensitive points also the
private sector
so i think that this is something that
is a cautious um
nearing a
of engagement and it is a a situation
that is driven by events that's obvious
you know the united states also for its
domestic constituencies needs to be
showing that it's doing something to
alleviate oil and gas prices also in the
united states so optically that is part
of the reason why he went to uh saudi
arabia is to say to the american people
look i'm doing this for for this is a
part of foreign policy for the middle
class i'm trying to deliver at home but
it's going to take time for those kind
of policies to yield dividends susanna
how do you see it would you say
as as tyson does that there are reasons
to believe that the u.s still has a
strong relationship
with countries in the middle east or
could this perceived kowtow to saudi
arabia actually heard it particularly in
the eyes of strategic rivals and
adversaries
it's definitely so that saudi arabia has
a close has close ties with with with
the us still they're very much dependent
on uh
weapons
deliveries and their contracts
long-running contracts i mean there is
no way that saudi arabia could say we
don't want to have anything to do with
u.s any longer or vice versa
so
it's more about strategic
as demonstration demonstration of a
strategic move uh the u.s is making here
they want to show to iran to russia um
we are still in we are still
having a leverage here the
it was also a sign that the times when
uh saudi arabia was isolated because of
the murder of jamal khashoggi that
this this chapter is closed now so um so
but this has a price and the price is um
uh showing showing that um that this
close cooperation is still in place and
it's a deal i mean they also get quite
quite uh a leeway now to work on their
issues with iran at the same time saudi
arabia is interested and america is
interested to keep the the ceasefire in
yemen and and all this is a it's it's a
package it's a big package and what what
tyson just
just mentioned about uh the abrahamic
courts that um
the cooperation with israel which is a
new alliance which is bill has which is
going to be built up i mean is a shift
uh which they demonstrate yeah so eureka
if it's a package uh are the benefits uh
going to uh outweigh the costs in terms
of loss of uh
loss of that appearance of values and
and morally guided foreign policy that
biden had sworn to put in place well as
tyson said i think the main point was
that bryan wanted to bring down the oil
prices
and that might work but the problem is
that the
prices for crude oil are not the main
problem because the prices for crude oil
are not higher than they were let's say
in 2011. the problem is that you have a
shortage of refining capacity
and so the oil is not that expensive the
crude oil is not that expensive but
diesel and gasoline are very very
expensive now and this will not change
because there are no
no refining capacities left so you know
in a way the problem for biden could be
that now everyone in the united states
is hoping that the
gas prices will go down and then all
these car drivers will somehow realize
that
for some reason it's still very
expensive
to go to the petrol station so that
might be a problem
those very high gasoline prices and i've
just come from the u.s
i cannot remember at any time in my life
paying these kind of prices at the pump
they are of course imperiling the
chances not only of joe biden but also
of his party in the upcoming midterm
elections and possibly in the
presidential election in
2024. do you really expect
that
voters will see this trip to the middle
east as having a significant effect that
wasn't my impression listening to u.s
media well the first point is the gas
prices have been starting to come down
slightly but consistently in the united
states the second thing is that
inflation is not only the number one
policy issue in washington and also for
the biden administration but also the
number one foreign policy issue for
washington and the um the narrative the
way that biden has the administration
has tried to frame it is in terms of
this war that russia's war on ukraine
has created all sorts of uh supply
bottlenecks that are driving up prices
in all sorts of areas fuel gas or energy
uh food etc commodities
and anything that he can be doing that
will substantively or opt
optically look like it's working against
that will be helpful but i don't know if
it will change the outcome of the
midterms
susana let's come back to the summit uh
in iran uh putin erdogan and iranian
president rajisi were doing their best
to present a united front but weren't
there very real divisions especially on
syria absolutely i mean actually you
have a lot of very contradictive
interests but on the other hand they
have also a couple of common things like
for instance they they they see a chance
to um
to change the regional uh order or even
the global order in the world and that's
something which is unifying them
you have also
um i mean everybody has a different
interest now iran and russia were on one
side in in syria and turkey was on the
other side
turkey is supporting ukraine with
delivery of drones which have been
extremely successful and very deadly on
the other hand uh um uh erdogan is one
who wants to make himself indispensable
when it comes to to mediate between um
ukraine and and russia so a very a very
clever move i have to say um
so
what what what is unifying them uh at
the moment um is stronger than what is
uh uh what is um
dividing them what is dividing them and
so um and so i think i think right now
it's a it's a demonstration of everybody
is doing its best to look as powerful as
possible and
you said dividing them uh eureka
nonetheless uh this uh
meeting in tehran definitely sent a very
clear message to the world could we in
some sense say that it's western
sanctions themselves that are enabling a
new form of geopolitics
not only in terms of this
russian-iranian
turkish nexus but of course also russia
china which will have blowback for the
west
well of course
we are somehow returning to an era that
we thought was over forever because now
we have again this block system on the
one hand we have the west
the western democratic
states and on the other hand we have
china and russia who are forming an
alliance and are somehow the biggest
dictatorships they are on earth and now
the interesting thing is that this
conflict of systems is being framed as a
conflict between democracies and
dictatorships and these dictatorships
are framed as offering security and
stability which in fact they don't offer
because that's what russia shows when
attacking the ukraine that it is a very
unstable country but anyway what i
really found interesting about this
whole meeting is that
it is really
a change that now is iran
offering drones to russia because you
know russia was always economically a
very poor country but it was a military
superpower and now iran which is somehow
not a very important country
it offers
a deadly weapons to a military
superpower and that really shows how
weak russia has become
that is now dependent on countries like
iran you know we don't know
right now whether this deal will come
through but nonetheless talking about it
is already a deadly blow for russia and
putin travels to iran and smiles all the
time i mean that's really just crazy
let's also take a look at the state of
the russian economy the west has in fact
heaped sanctions on russia yet as energy
prices soar and supplies of gas dwindle
many here in europe fear that these
measures are hurting the west more than
putin
from burgers
to porsches the list of products that
can no longer be sold in russia is long
president putin is now complaining about
an economic blitzkrieg by the west
admitting that the sanctions are
affecting russia
as a result the russian gdp is expected
to fall by 10 percent in 2022
inflation is currently at 17
and industrial production has fallen by
8
but many of the sanctions are also
affecting germany and other western
countries
food and energy prices are skyrocketing
many consumers are already complaining
about the high prices
some economic experts say that the world
economy might be in danger
the russian president has managed to
find new buyers for many of his raw
materials faster than expected including
in india and china
and expensive western products such as
luxury cars are easily imported through
other countries like turkmenistan or
kazakhstan
with its sanctions will the west harm
itself more than russia in the end
and let me put that question right to
urrica coupled
with a question that arose uh as i was
reading a very interesting article in
the magazine published uh by uh the the
spiegel uh the magazine that susana
writes for the historian nicholas mulder
said there that if you want to wage
economic war you must put your economy
on a war footing did the west fail to
remember that lesson as it began
applying sanctions
well perhaps but you have to distinguish
two things those sanctions that we
decided on not to export any high
technology to russia or not to
to serve the
airplanes is not hurting the best at all
because you know russia was very
unimportant when it came to exports the
the russian the german exports to russia
were only 2.5 percent of all the exports
germany has so that was really a minor
point but of course russia can hurt us
by just not exporting oil or gas and
that's what they are doing so but that
is something you could
never ever have prevented because once
the west starts to support
the ukraine with weapons
which i find uh that we should do that
then of course it was obvious that
the russia would retaliate by
using its oil and its gas as a weapon by
itself so there was no possibility to
somehow prevent russia
to use its energy as a weapon but of
course that is something that europe
didn't really um
provide for but i think that's just
because you know no one counted
on having this war to the february 24th
everyone's thought
it's impossible that russia would attack
the ukraine and now of course uh
europe starts to adapt to this situation
but in the end you know what we have to
do is to save energy it's obvious so
let's talk about saving energy in the
face of a lot of speculation susanna
that
russia would now completely cut off gas
through the nordstrom one gas pipeline
to europe in fact it is now flowing
again is this just a ruse on putin's
part to keep europe nice and dependent
on russian gas or do you think that
russia in the end needs europe at least
as much as europe needs that russian gas
certainly i mean we are still the the
the the biggest recipients of of of gas
so certainly there is an indep
interdependency but on the other hand
it's also a kind of it adds to the to
the war it adds a kind of psychological
warfare as well because i mean it's
terrorizing everybody here like you
don't know
would he would he open the pipe uh
pipeline again or wouldn't he and when
does he stop and and and i mean that's
that's that's a level of of uh of of
discussion on uh politically which is
actually something everybody wants to
avoid and um
certainly it it it shows that the
dependency and we all know now that it
was a big mistake to completely rely on
russia what also has to say that even in
the in the in the harshest most darkest
moments during the cold war i mean
there's it has never happened that uh
that that russia didn't deliver
didn't deliver when you had a contract
with it so actually it's it's a complete
new situation so uh who whom do you want
to blame but the lesson learned is
certainly you need a complete new mix
which you set up so if if if you have
trouble with one with one contract
partner so you never fall into that
situation again and tyson meanwhile the
eu commission is recommending two member
states that they should begin to prepare
for rationing gas is that the beginning
of that war footing for the european
economy that could help it out last
a long cold winter with less russian gas
yeah that's the appropriate response
response i mean this is an acute crisis
that very few people predicted there is
a chronic crisis that people are already
starting to predict for and build
resilience and to build that kind of
war-footing economy and that's china so
thinking about diversifying on a
semiconductor production for example
away from taiwan or some other areas
there is an attempt to to create the
kind of resilience you need to be able
to survive when you're cut off from
major uh major economies but we have to
say i mean we should not be afraid of
our own shadow
the the
greater west is 45 percent of the global
economy russia is under 2
so the elephant can't be afraid of the
mouse in this case the question is
always a question as it is in economics
short term or a longer term many people
or we could say that this conflict is
likely to last quite a wee while
i want to come back to our title we
asked whether
it's anything goes for putin and biden
will these new friendships that putin is
cultivating will they take enough of the
sting out of western sanctions that he
can
keep on going
indefinitely
no the sanctions the western sanctions
are very uh
forceful because they hit at two points
that are vital for the russian economy
one is a
high technology and the other is the
arab airplanes and without the western
technology all the planes in russia must
stay on the ground and that is for a
huge country like russia deadly susanna
tyson in one word would you say that the
west has what it takes to stay the
course also through its alliances even
through a long cold winter
it will be a little bit cold in this
winter maybe next winter in particularly
but on the long run i'm quite positive
russia has to lose this war that is the
commitment that the biden administration
has made in brussels has made and we
have to stick to our commitment to
ukraine
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us and thanks to all of you
out there for tuning in see you soon